Alright, so we're going to be starting chapter 8. It's broken down to two parts, chapter
A and a part B. If you have any questions, please email me or send me a message through
YouTube. In addition, you can also leave me in the comments below. If you like it, please
give this video a thumbs up. Please be sure to subscribe as soon as the new videos are
up. You guys will get immediate notification. And also, if there's any other material that
you'd like, please let me know of that as well. So, beginning with chapter 8, this is
on deceptors, on joints. Now, a joint, or also, also known as articulations, are points
where you have two or more bones that come together. So whenever you have two or more
bones that are meeting, we say that they're articulating. So that's an articulation point.
So joints, they connect two bones together, their points are over where two bones meet.
In addition to that, joints, they also provide mobility between the two bones as well. Or
they may be able to provide mobility if it's a movable joint. As you're going to learn
in this chapter, some joints, there is absolutely no motion at all. Other joints, there's a wide
degree of motion that they provide. Now, all the joints are the weakest part of the skeleton.
There are structures. There is this various forces, such as crushing or tearing, that
they're into misaligned them. Now, joints, they're classified by structure and function.
Now, when we're talking about structure, we're talking about what materials are present
that binds the joints together. In addition to that, we're also looking at if there is a cavity
that's present or not. Now, there's three types of structural joints that we're going to be looking
at. These three are fibrous, cartilaginous, and synovial joints. Now, the second classification
is the functional classification. And we're talking about how much movement the joint allows.
So, the three types of joints that we're going to be looking at are synothorotic joints, where
there is literally no movement at all. Then there's an inferior thorotic joint that allows a slight
degree of motion between the two bones. And then there's a diothorotic joint. Now,
these diothoroses, these are the most freely movable joints. They provide a very wide
degree of motion to occur. Now, as far as these most freely movable joints, you're going to find
these mostly at your limbs. So, just about all your limbs, another way to look at it, with the
exception of everything that you have in your midline. So, we're talking about everything that's
part of your appendicular skeleton. You're going to find diothorotic joints here. But the majority
of the joints here, they're going to be all diothorotic joints. Now, we're going to be moving
forward. So, the first thing that we're going to be looking at are the structural classifications
that we talked about. So, now the very first type of structural joint that we mentioned was the
fibrous joint. Now, bones in a fibrous joint, they're connected by dense fibrous connective tissue.
They lack a joint cavity. And the majority of these, you're not going to find any motion at all.
So, if there is, there's going to be a tiny amount of, well, more or less, it's like a
slight even motion, but it's more of a give that's present. And usually, the amount of moving that's
allowed, that's, it's determined by more specifically the length of the connected tissue fibrous that
are bringing those two bones together. Now, the three types of fibrous joints that are present
are switchers, sin-desmosis, and the gumphosis. Now, the only place we're going to find switchers
are between the bones of your skull. The wavy are articulate in bone edges of the skulls. They
interlock with one another. Now, and the junction that we have, it gets completely filled by the
middle amount of these very short connected tissue fibers that run continuous with the periocene.
Now, what ends up in return, what ends up happening is you have a very rigid
splices that end up knitting the bones together. But at the same time, it does give the skull
the ability to expand during the youth. Now, after youth during the middle ages,
that those fibrous tissue, they ossify, and now you end up having the skull bones that completely
fuse together into a single unit. Now, at this stage, when the switchers are closed and they're ossified,
now we call them the turn that we use to describe them are sin-desmosis. Now, in this picture here,
you can see the bones of the skulls, the flat bones over here. And then, so when you see these
little wavy parts of the bones, these are both of these, they end up kind of like, think about it,
it's kind of like a jigsaw puzzle. So when they come, you know, these pieces, they come together,
they end up locking within themselves. Now, didn't you think that what's going to further
secure this place are is the connective tissue they find between the ridges of these bones. So,
now, keep in mind, it's not a movable joint, but during youth, even though it doesn't move,
it provides the ability for it to expand. As a child's brain is growing, and into young adult,
into young adulthood, as the brain grows, the skull is also growing, it allows for this to occur.
But again, later on in life, during your middle ages, this is going to be gone, okay. This car
fibrous connective tissue is going to be completely ossified. And this is when you end up, this is,
you know, when you end up calling this, the synastosis, okay. Now, this entire skull is going to be a
single unit at that point. Now, we're going to be looking at the next type of structural joint,
syndismosis. Now, in syndismosis, bones are connected exclusively by ligaments, bands,
or cords of fibrous connective tissue. Now, the amount of movement allowed depends on the length
of the connecting fibrous. Now, regardless of the length, you're only going to get a slight amount
of motion in this type of joint. For example, when you look at the ligaments connecting the
dissonance of the tibion fibula, the tissue that's connecting it, it's quite short. Now,
so what you end up getting is a very slight movement that occurs over here. It's not even
more movement, but it's better described as a give that's present. Functionally, this type
of joint will classify as synarthrotic. Now, on the other hand, the fibers of the ligaments
that are connecting to the radius and ulna, which is the intralysis membrane, it allows for the
radius to cross over the ulna when you're pronating and supinating your arm. And this happens because
the fibers are long enough. So, therefore, we would classify this functionally as a diarthritic joint.
So, when you look at this distal tibial fibular joint, this ligament right here, this is the
anterior-inferior tibial fibular ligament. And this would be an example of this synarthosis.
So, you're not getting any motion over here. More or less, what you're getting is the type of
movement you're getting is you're getting a little bit of a give between these two bones.
So, moving forward, we're going to be looking at gomphosis. Now, in gomphosis, what you have is a
peg in a socket fibers joint. And the only place that we have this type of joint is in the articulation
of your teeth with the alveolar socket. And now, remember, what do you find this? You find this
what two bones you find in the mandible and your maxilla. The maxilla, remember, is the upper
bone that holds your upper teeth in place. And the mandible is going to be the main bone that
holds your lower teeth in place. So, the fibers connection in gomphosis are the periodontal ligaments
which hold the teeth in the socket. So, when you look over here, here's your tooth right over here.
And now, this is a mandible. So, this is your lower jaw that we're looking at. And this is the alveolar
process. And so, what's holding these two bones are these periodontal ligaments, okay?
Now, in cartlaginous joints, the bones are united by cartilage. And as we saw in fibers joints,
they also lack a joint cavity. In addition to that, they're not highly immovable as well.
Now, the two types of cartlaginous joints that we're going to be looking at are synchondrosis
and symphysis. Now, a bar or plate of heartline cartilage will unite the bones at a synchondrosis.
Now, just about all joints that are synchondrosis are synarthritic, which means they're not movable.
So, examples of this would be the temporary joint joint that we find at the FSCO place in the long
bones of children. Eventually, they become synan ptosis after the plate closes. In addition,
between the manubrium and your first rib, we also find this kind, we also find a synchondrosis
there. Now, in this picture, you can see the FSCO plate over here. So, this would be an example
of synchondrosis. And again, this is the long bone in children. And remember, these two bones,
the epiphysis and the diaphysis, they're united by synchondrosis. So, then this is a synchondratic
joint, meaning this is not movable. And then the other place that we see it as I discussed earlier,
this is the manubrium and this is your first clavicle. So, again, this is another example of
a synchondratic joint. This is not movable. It's an immovable joint. Now, in a synthesis,
the articular surface of the bones, they're aligned with hyaline cartilage or articular cartilage.
Now, this articular cartilage, it's fused with an intravenous pad or plate of fibrocartilage.
Now, this fibrocartilage, this is the main connecting material. Now, synthesis, they're strong.
However, they are slightly movable. So, they're amphiarthratic. Now, examples of where we find
synthesis are the discs between your vertebraes, so the intervertebral joints. In addition to that,
we also find it at the pubic synthesis. So, when you look over here, again, right over here, this is
a synthesis. This is between two backbone. So, this is the fibrocart, it's a fibrocart
laginous intervertebral disc. So, what we find over here, we're going to find hyaline cartilage
that's going to be lining here. And then, in between, you have the fibrocartilage.
And then, again, where the anteriorly, where your hip bone meets, this is the pubic synthesis.
This is the pubic region and the pubic synthesis. If you guys remember what this part of the bone was,
anybody take a guess? Remember, this is the ilium, this is the isium, and this bone is the
pubis. So, at the articular surface of the two pubis, the pubi, we have hyaline cartilage,
and then you're going to have this fibrocartilage. This is the main connecting material. So, again,
in the synthesis, at this pubic synthesis, we have, again, this is the other place where you find
this joint. Now, what we find at synovial joints are where the articulating bones, they're separated
by a fluid containing joint cavity. And this arrangement is what allows the bones to have an
enormous degree of motion. Now, these are very freely movable joints. And so, therefore, they're
classified as being diarthrotic. Now, just about all the joints that you find at your limbs are
diarthrotic joints, or in other words, they are synovial joints. Now, we're going to be looking at
characteristics of synovial joints. As we move forward, one of the first things we're going
to be talking about are the six general features that we find in synovial joints. Also associated
with the synovial joints, we have bursa and tendon sheets. In addition to that, what we're
going to be discussing, what stabilizes these synovial joints? Obviously, when you have a very
large degree of motion, you need to have some, you need to have a special structure to help
stabilize this joint. So, we're going to be looking at the shapes of the articular surface of the bones,
ligaments, and muscles. These are the primary things that help stabilize this joint.
We're also going to be looking at the classification of the different types of joints.
There's six to name. There's a hinge joint we find. There's a pivot joint. We find a bone socket
joint, a plane joint, saddle joint, and also a condily joint. We're going to be looking at all
these things as we move forward in the lecture. Now, we're going to be talking about the six
general features that we see at synovial joints. Now, the very first thing that we see is this
glassy, smooth, hyaling cartilage that covers the articular and bone surfaces as articular cartilage.
Now, the articular cartilage, although it's less than a millimeter in thickness,
it acts as a spongy cushion that absorbs the compression that's placed on the joints,
and this is what keeps the bone ass from being crushed. A feature that we find unique to
synovial joints is the joint cavity. Now, this is just a potential space that contains a small
amount of synovial fluid. Now, the joint cavity is enclosed by a double-layer articular capsule,
or what we call a joint capsule. The external layer is a tough fibrous capsule that's made up
of dense irregular connective tissue that's continuous with the periastia of the articular bones,
and what it does is it helps straighten the joint so the bones do not pull apart. Now,
the inner layer of the joint capsule is a synovial membrane that's made up of loose connective tissue.
Now, aside from lining the fibrous capsules internally, it also covers all the internal joint
surfaces that aren't covered by hyaling cartilage. Now, a small amount of synovial fluid
occupies all the free space within a joint capsule. Now, the fluid is derived largely by
filtration from blood that's flowing through the capillars in the synovial membrane. Now,
synovial fluid is quite viscous, meaning it's thick. In fact, this consistency is almost like
egg whites. Now, this is because of the hyaluronic acid that's created by the synovial membranes.
This fluid, it does become less viscous as the joint starts to warm up. Now, synovial fluid,
it also lubricates and nourishes the articular cartilage. In addition to that, it also contains
phagocytic cells that remove microbes and debris. Now, what synovial fluid does is that it provides
a slippery weight-bearing film that reduces friction between the cartilage. Now, if you
didn't have this lubrication, what's going to end up happening is the ends, they're going to start
rubbing against one another, and then eventually you end up eroding or burning away the cartilage
just there. If this continues on, the next thing that's going to happen is you're going to have
bone-on-bone friction. In other words, now the bones are going to start, they're going to start
rubbing each other away, and this is the worst thing that can happen. Eventually, you're not
going to be able to move that joint. Now, the synovial fluid, it gets forced into cartilage
when the joint is compressed, and then when the pressure is relieved, the fluid is going to end
up seeping back into the articular cartilage. This is kind of like how a sponge works also.
This process is called this weeping lubrication. Synovial joints are reinforced and straightened
by a number of ligaments. A majority of the time, they're capsular or intrinsic ligaments,
which are thick in parts of the fibrous capsule. Other times, they remain distinct and they're found
outside the capsule as extra capsular ligaments. Other times, they're found deep to it,
and which is called intra-capsular ligaments. Synovial joints, they have a very rich supply of
nerves and blood vessels. Now, the nerves, they're mostly there to monitor the joint position
and stretch. This is what helps maintain the muscle tone, and the rich blood supply that the
synovial joint gets. It is what helps form the filtrate that we find for the synovial fluid.
So, in this illustration, we see a synovial joint. So, here are the two articulating bones,
and you can see that the articulating bones, they're aligned with this articular cartilage
at the articulating surface. Now, we see this fibrous layer here, the outer fibrous layer,
and then we have this inner synovial membrane that forms the articular capsule. The spaces between
within this capsule, it constitutes the joint cavity, and as within this joint cavity, we will
find the synovial fluid. We also see this outer ligament over here. Now, this would be an example
of this capsular ligament, and this thickens the fibrous layer to reinforce and straighten this
joint. Now, aside from the six basic components that we talked about, certain synovial joints,
they have other structural features. For example, in your hip and knee joints, they have these
cushioning fatty pads that we find between the fibrous capsule and the synovial membrane or bone.
Now, other places, they have discs or wedges of fibrocarture that separate the articular surfaces.
Now, where you have these, you call them articular discs or mini-sky. Now, these articular disc
or mini-sky, they extend inward from the articular capsule, and they either partially or completely
divide the synovial cavity in two. Now, birds on tenon sheets, they're not strictly part of
the synovial joints, but they are found closely associated with them. Essentially, what they are
are bags of lubricants that access ball bearings that reduces friction between the adjacent structures
during joint activity. Now, bursa, they're flattened fibrous sacs that are lined with
synovial membranes, and they contain a thin film of synovial fluid. Now, we find these
where ligaments, muscles, skins, tendons, or bones, they rub together. Now, a tendon sheet,
essentially, is just an elongated bursa that wraps completely around a tendon that's subjected
to friction. So, it kind of looks like a bun that's around a hot dog. They're common where
several tendons are crowded together within a narrow canals. So, for example, in the wrist region,
is a great, great example. So, in this illustration, it shows you a frontal section of your right
shoulder joint. So, we have your articulating bones over here, and so, notice what we have
is this fiber, the outer fibers layer of the articular capsule. You have the articular
cartilage over here. You have your synovial joint over here. And, of course, you have the
inner synovial membrane that's lining this capsule. What else can we see over here? And
then you see the tendon of the long head of your biceps brachii muscle. Now, the area of interest
is the bursa. So, we're going to be looking at this subachromial bursa over here. And notice that
we have this bursa between the ligament and bone over here, and this bone over here, or this joint.
So, if you look over here, this is a close-up now. So, we find this bursa where we have this
ligament that's overlining this bone. And what it's doing is preventing these two surfaces
from rubbing together. So, this will roll around. It absorbs it. Remember, it's loose. It's
questioning. So, this is what a bursa will do. So, notice this is a flattened disc. Now,
sometimes when you have injury, now, keep in mind, they are lined with synovial membrane
room. That means they have a rich blood supply. So, if there is an injury, some type of trauma,
oftentimes what happens is that it will become, it will fill up with fluid. And when it starts
to fill up with fluid, what's going to happen is it starts to enlarge. And when it enlarges,
now you have, you decrease range of motion, and of course, pain that's associated with it.
So, what has to happen is you have to go to your doctor or emergency room, and they need to
aspirate that fluid out of the sac. And once you remove that fluid, again, that's going to be blood,
then you're going to end up relieving that pain and also restoring motion back to this joint.
Now, because joints are constantly stretched and compressed, we have to worry about
dislocating them. So, they need to be stabilized. Now, we, earlier on, we talked about the three
things that stabilize the joint. So, let's talk a little bit more about it in detail now. Now,
the first thing is the shape of the articular surface. Now, this plays a role, but not a major
role in stability. So, generally speaking, the more shallow the surface is, the less stable it is.
And the greater the surface that we have, or in other words, whenever we have larger
articular surfaces that are fit snugly together, or when you have deep sockets,
as we do in the example of a ball and socket joint, these are the best and most stable type
of joints. Now, the other thing are ligaments and their number and their location. This also
plays a limited role. However, with that said, the more ligaments that you're going to have,
the stronger the joint is going to be. Now, the most important of three things is muscle tone.
So, muscle tone, this is essentially what it is, is the, when muscles are relaxed,
this is the amount of contractivity it still has. In other words, when a muscle is relaxed,
the tendons, it's still under a certain degree of contraction. And when this tone, it is what
pulls on the muscle tendon that's attached to the joint, and it is what helps keeps
the bones in place. This is extremely important in reinforcing your shoulder and your knee joints,
as well as the arch of your foot. Now, let's look at, in these illustrations over here,
you have this, I'm sorry, not illustration. There is an illustration, but you also have this chart
over here. So, it's going to be talking about the type of joints that we have over here.
So, when you look at your skull, the articulating bones are the cranial and your facial bones,
and the structural type is this fibrous sutures that we have. And these are synathrotic joints,
meaning there's no movement that's allowed. Now, when you look at your temporal mandibular joint,
so the bones obviously will be the mandible, which is your jaw bone, and the bones of your skull.
Now, this is a synovial joint. It's a modified hinge joint, which has this articulating disc there.
It's diatrototic. It provides gliding and uniaxial rotation. It has slight lateral movement,
elevation and depression, protraction and retraction as well. Now, we're going to be talking about all
these movements, but before we get to that, let me just mention that there are six types of synovial
joints. These are hinge joints, pivot joints, ball and socket joints, plane joints, saddle joints,
and chondyloid joints. We'll be talking about these in the second part of the lecture for this
chapter for chapter 8. But let's move forward. We have this Atlanta occipital joint, and as the name
applies, it's the occipital bones of the skull and the atlas very first bone of your cervical spine.
And this is also a synovial chondyloid joint. It's diatrototic. It's a biaxial,
flexion, extension, lateral flexion, circumduction of the head and on your neck. So again, you have
a very wide degree of motion over here. The next one is this Atlanta axial joint. And this is
where you have, again, as the name implies, your atlas and axis T1 and C2 articulating.
And it's a synovial pivot joint. It is diatrototic. However, this one is uniaxial. And what it does
is it just allows the rotation of your head. So remember, this lets you rotate your head from side
to side as in it's when you're nodding no. Whereas the first one was, you know, you're nodding yes
in addition to, you know, you can rotate your head around, flexed, extended. Now you have your
introvertibral discs. So again, the bones that are involved are the bones, the vertebrae that are
adjacent to you, the ventral bodies. It's a cartlaginous symphysis. It's amphiothrotic,
meaning that it has slight degree of motion. Now, also, between the articular processes of the
the introvertibral disc, there's also a synovial or plane joint, which are diatrotic gliding
along the the coastal, the castor vertebral vertebral. So in other words, we're talking about
the bones of the urebs and the vertebrae where they come together, the transverse process
or bodies. You have a synovial plane. This is also a diatrototic joint where in other words, you have
slight gliding of the ribs taking place here. Let's look at, now, in the front parts over here,
we have your anterior thorax. You have your sternoclavicular joint. So again, as a name implies,
you have your sternum and clavicle that are articulating. And this is a synovial joint.
It's shallow saddle joint. It is also contains an articulating disc. It's diatrotic. It's
multiaxial. It allows the clavicle to move in all the axes. Now, the sternocostal, the first
sternum and rib one, it's a cartlaginous synchondratic joint. There is no movement. So we say that is
synarthritic. Now, the remaining sternocostal, sternocostal joints, ribs 2 through 12. Again,
these are synovial. They're double-plained. They're diatrototic gliding joint. So when you look at
your limbs, now your upper limb, you have your chromioclavicular joint. And articulating bones
here are their chromian of your scapula and clavicle. And structurally, this is also a synovial joint.
It's a plane joint. It's diatrototic. It has gliding and rotation of your scapula on your
clavicle. When you look at the glenohumeral joint, you're talking about your shoulder over here,
the bones that are articulating are the scapula and the humerus, the head of the humerus.
And it's a synovial joint. It's a ball and socket type of joint, the type of synovial joint.
Now, it's diatrototic, multiaxial. So again, diatrotty, you have a lot of motion over here.
You have flexion, extension, adduction, adduction, circumduction, rotation of your humerus.
And don't worry about this. We're going to be talking about what all these motions are in the
coming slides. Elbow, now your elbow joint. Again, the bones are, as you guys know already,
your radius and ulna, along with your humerus. So this is a hinge joint. It's a type of
synovial joint. It's diatrototic uniaxial. You have flexion and extension of your forearm here.
The proximal radial ulnar, you have the bones that are articulating are the radius and the ulna.
It's a synovial joint also, pivot joint, diatrototic, uniaxial motion. You get pivoting
the convex head of the radius. It rotates with the radial notch of the ulna. At the distal
radial ulnar joint, you have your radius and ulna again. And it's a synovial joint. It's a pivot,
and it also contains an articular disc. It's diatrototic uniaxial type of joint.
So again, you have a lot of wide degree of motion, rotation of the radius around the
long axis of your forearm. And this is what allows you to turn your arm up and down,
upwards and down. So if you take your palms and you put your arms towards the ceiling and
downwards again, this is the motion that allows, which is called pronation and supination.
The wrist joints, again, you have your radius and your proximal carples,
scaphoid, lunatic, trichrytron, and pissiform. Now, it's a synovial joint,
condler. It's diatrototic, biaxial allows reflection, extension, abduction, adduction,
and circumduction of the hand. Now, the intracarpal, these are the adjacent carples. It's a synovial
plane. It's just a diatrototic gliding joint. Now, gliding motion. Now, the carpal metacarpal
of the first stage is your thumb. The bones that are involved are the trapezium, and the first
metacarpal bone. Remember trapezium, this is one of the carples, okay? And you have a saddle joint
here. It's a synovial joint type of synovial joint as a saddle. It's diatrototic, biaxial,
it also flexion, extension, abduction, adduction, circumduction, and opposition of metacarpal one.
So think about all the motions that you have in your thumb. What could you do? You can flex it.
You can extend it. You can move it towards your pinky finger. You can move it away from the pinky
finger. You can rotate it, okay? You can, in other words, you can twirl your thumb in a circle,
and also you can touch all your other fingers. These are all what these motions are. Again,
like I said, we'll be looking at these motions in the next few slides, so don't worry about it.
If you sign this lecture, it's going to be in the next lecture in part B. We have your
carpal metacarpals of digits 2 to 5, and again, you have your carples and metacarpals over here.
And it's a synovial planar joint diatrototic, and you have gliding of the metacarpals here.
Now, the metacarpal flangeal joints are in knuckles. These are in the metacarpals and
the proximal phalanx, and its synovial joint is condular diatrototic biaxial joint. So you have
flexion, extension, abduction, adduction, and circumduction of the fingers. Now, the interphalangeal
joints, your finger, these are the adjacent flanges, is a synovial hinge joint,
is diatrototic, but it's uniaxial. So it just allows for flexion and extension of your fingers.
Now let's look to the lower limbs. So this is the first thing we're going to be talking about,
is your sacral iliac joint. So the bones that are involved here are the sacrum and the coxal bones.
Now, this is a synovial joint as well, and it's again plain and childhood, and increasingly,
it turns fibrous in adults. Remember, the bones fuse. So it's diatrototic in child and amphiarthrotic
in adults. Now, the pubic symphysis, the pubic bone, it's a cartilaginous symphysis. It's amphiarthrotic,
now it allows slight movement. So again, during pregnancy, when you're delivering, this is what
kind of helps allow this, that the pubic bone to separate a little or stretch out a little bit
during the delivery of the child. You have your coxal bone over here, your hip joint,
and what you have is the hip bone. And remember specifically, you have your talking about your
acetabulum and the head of the femur. So this is a synovial joint. It's a bone socket joint.
It's diatrotic, multi-axial, flexion, extension, abduction, adduction, rotation,
circumduction of your thighs. Now your knee joint, your tibial femoral joint,
as the name implies, the bones that are articulating are your femur and tibia.
It's a synovial, it's a modified hinge joint, and it also contains articular discs. It's diatrotatic
biaxial, so this allows for flexion and extension of your leg. It does allow some degree of rotation,
just allowed in the flex position. Now also, you have your femoral patellar joint as a knee,
the name implies, your femur, and patella. In other words, your knee. Synovial plane joint
is diatrotatic, and it allows the patellar to glide. You have your superior tibular
joint, and the bones is the tibia and the fibula, again, proximally. So it's right over here,
where the tibia and the fibula, they articulate proximally to the body. And then you have another
one there, it's an articulate distally. So over here, it's a synovial joint, it's a plane joint,
it's diatrotatic, and it allows the fibula to glide. Did your inferior tibular joint,
the tibia and fibula, again, where they articulate distally, it's fibrous,
sendous moses, it's synatrotatic. Remember, what do you have? No motion, it just gives a slight
amount of give during dorsiflexion. Your ankle joint, you have your tibia and fibula with
your talus, and that's the bone that's articulating with your tibia. It's a synovial joint,
it's a plane joint, diatrotatic, and it allows gliding of the metatarsals. Then you have your
metatarsal phalangeal joints. Yes, and then what do we have here? Your metatarsals and the proximal
phalanx, it's a synovial joint, it's a condular, it's diatrotatic joint, which allows biaxial
motion. You get flexion, extension, abduction, adduction, circumduction of your toe,
or your helix. The interferential joints we have here are the adjacent phalanges,
and what we have here is a synovial hinge joint. It's diatrotatic, you have uniaxial motion here,
flexion, extension of your toes. All muscles, they attach to bones or connect to tissue at no
less than two points. Now, the origin, this is attached into the bone that's not moving,
okay, to the movable bone. The bone that's going to be moving is referred to as the insertion point.
So, muscles, they contract, when they contract, they cause the insertion to move towards the origin,
and movement occurs along the transverse, frontal or sagittal planes. Now, the range of motion
that's allowed by synovial joints, they could be non-axial, meaning that you only have a slipping
movement. They could be uniaxial, meaning you have movement in one plane. They could be biaxial,
meaning you have movement in two planes. When you have movement in all three planes or in all around,
then you call that multi-axial. The general types of movements that we have are gliding,
angular movements, and rotation. Now, gliding movement is when we have one flat bone surface
that glides or slips over another similar surface. So, for example, in your intercarpal joints,
intertarsal joints, and also between the articulator process of the vertebrae, are examples of gliding
movement. So, you look over here, as the palm is going from side to side, these carpal bones,
they're gliding. So, it is where you have this gliding movement. The angular movement, as the name implies,
it affects the angle between the two bones. It's either increasing or decreasing that angle.
So, movement is along a sagittal plane. Angular movement, they include flexion and extension,
as well as hyper extension. Now, flexion, it decreases the angle of the joint, whereas
extension increases the angle of the joint. And hyper extension, it provides movement
beyond anatomical position. So, when you look over here, when you're taking your chin and you're
trying to touch your chest, that's a flexion. When you move your chin away from your chest,
back straight upwards into the anatomical position, then that would be extension. Then, when you're
taking the back of your head and you're trying to tilt your shoulder, for example,
you're hyper extending. Yes, hyper extension. So, again, another example, when you're bending
forward, when you're like, when you're bowing, that's flexion, when you stand back up straight,
that would be extending. And then, when you're stretching your back towards all the way to the
back, as when you're trying to crack your back, that would be hyper extending or hyper extension.
You can see over here also, look at the knees. When she's making this angle smaller, that's flexing.
When she straightens it back out, that's extension. So, you have flexion, extension of this joint
over here, of your lower limb. Obviously, you cannot hyper extend. Same thing with the arm.
Notice, she's flexing it over here, and then she's extending it. Same thing, if you take her arm,
and you know, she'd bring it upwards, if you want to see the bicep move, and the bicep contracts,
it will pull this arm upwards, your forearm upwards, that would be flexion.
And then, when the biceps relaxes, this muscle up over here, then that would be extension.
Abduction, adduction. Now, when you look at this term, ab ab, that means a way. So, when you have
movement along the frontal plane, that's away from the midline of the body, is abduction.
And then, adduction, you have movement of the, again, so you have movement along the frontal
plane towards the midline of the body. So, when you move your, you know, you're standing in the
anatomical position, and you move your arms away from the body, that would be adducting. Then,
we're going to move them back towards the midline of the body, that would be adduction.
Now, circumduction, this involves flexion, adduction, extension, and adduction of,
I'm sorry, let me say that again, circumduction involves flexion, adduction, adduction of your limbs.
So, when we look at the next picture over here, this is certain induction. So, when you're rotating
your arms, you're making circles with it, that's circumduction. Abduction, notice what you're doing,
you're taking your arms, you're moving away from the midline of your body, adducting.
Then, adduction is when you're moving your arms back towards the midline of the body.
Now, rotation, this happens when you're turning the bones around its long axis towards the midline
or away from it, and we have medial rotation, that's towards the midline, and then you have lateral
rotation away from the midline. So, examples of this is rotation between your C1 and C2 vertebrae,
it's a very good example, and also of the rotation of the humerus. So, if you have your arms,
you're standing up, you have your arms hanging towards the sides, and then you rotate your
humerus. So, like your elbows are pointing towards the sides, elbows are pointing laterally,
that would be an example of rotation of your humerus, for example, and you can do the same thing with
your femur. So, when you look over here, again, also, you're turning C1 and C2, you have rotation
over here, as in when you're doing a no, and then again, if you look over here, you cannot see very
clearly in this picture, but you have your lateral rotation of the legs, so notice she has a pointed
outwards, and then medial rotation and she'd turn it back inwards. Now, special movements that we have
as sonuba joints are supination and pronation. So, this is the rotation of radius mioma. So, when you
have your palms facing towards the ceiling, that's called supination. Then, when you're taking your
palms and you're facing it downwards, that's pronation. Okay, dorsiflexion and plant reflection
of the foot, when you're driving a car and you're stomping on the gas, that's an example of plant
reflection. Now, when you lift your foot off the gas, that's an example of dorsiflexion.
So, here's your palm, we have it facing upwards, that's called supination. When you rotate it and
the palms facing downwards, that's pronation. Same thing with your foot. When you're stomping on the
gas, okay, you want to speed off at a green light, that's plant reflexing. And then, when you want
to take your foot off the gas pedal, that would be dorsiflexion. Inversion and eversion at the foot,
again, you're taking the sole of your feet and you're facing it medially, that's inversion,
and when you face it laterally, that would be eversion. Then, there's protraction and retraction.
So, yeah, movements in lateral planes. So, protecting the men when the men double jets out
and retraction was when your men was pulled back towards the neck. So, over here, you can see,
you can the sole of your foot facing medially, it's inversion, then when you're facing it laterally,
that's eversion. So, again, you have your mandible here and when she's projecting it forward,
that's protraction. And then, when she brings it back inwards towards the neck,
that's retraction, okay, protraction, retraction of the mandible. You also see this in pigeons
when pigeons walk, you'll see their necks move back and forth, back and forth, that's protraction
and retraction in pigeons. Now, elevation and depression, these are also movements that we see
at synovial joints. So, for example, when your elevation is lifting the body parts superiorly,
so when you're shrugging your shoulders upwards, that's elevation. Then, when you're shrugging,
you relax your shoulders back down, that would be depression. So, lowering the body part. So,
when you're opening your jaw, that's an example of depression, when you're closing it back up,
that's an example of elevation as well. Opposition, it allows movements of your thumb. So, when you
take your thumb and you touch the tips of your other fingers, your second, third, fourth and fifth
digits, that's an example of opposition. So, here you see the mandible is open, okay, so she's open
her mouth, her mandible move downwards, that's an example of depression. When she closes her mouth,
moves it back up, that's an example of elevation. So, again, if she shrugs her shoulder upwards,
brings her shoulder closer to her ears, that's elevating, then she brings it back downwards,
that would be depression, depression of the shoulders. Then, you can see opposition over here,
you're taking your thumb, you're touching your middle finger, your index finger and thumb,
middle finger and thumb, ring finger and thumb, pinky finger and thumb, these are all examples of
opposition. Now, there are six different types of synoleal joints and they're categorized based on
the shape of the articular surface, as well as the movement the joint is capable of. Now,
when playing joints are articular surfaces, they're essentially flat and they allow only a short
non-axx of gliding movement to occur. So, examples of gliding joints, we looked at a little bit earlier,
or at the inter-carpal and interstitial joints. In hinge joints, the cylindrical end of one bone,
it conforms to a traw-shaped surface on another. Now, motion is along a single plane and resembles
that of a mechanical hinge. Now, uniaxial hinge joints, they allow for only for flexion and for
extension to occur. Now, in a pivotal joint, what we see here is that the rounded end of one bone,
it conforms to a sleeve or ring composed of either bone or possibly a ligament of another.
The only movement that it's allowed is uniaxial rotation of one bone around its long axis.
In common with joints, also known as ellipsoidal joints, the oval's articulating surface of one
bone, it fits into complementary depression or another. Now, the important characteristic is that
both articulating surfaces, they're oval. Now, the bi-axxial coneloid joints, it permits all
angular motion circuit, meaning you get flexion and extension, abduction and adduction,
as well as circumduction. Now, in saddle joints, they resemble coneloid joints, but they allow
greater freedom of movement. Now, each arterial surface, it has both concave and convex areas.
In other words, it looks like a saddle. Now, the arterial surfaces, they fit together concave
to convex. Now, in a bone socket joints, the spherical or hemispherical head of one bone,
it articulates with the cup-like socket of another. Now, these joints are multi-axxial and the most
freely movable joint, single-wheel joint that we have in our body. So, it allows for universal
movement. Purpose examples is we see it at our shoulder joints or hip joints as well.
So, in this illustration, what you can see is a plane joint, and we're looking at your
inter-carpal joint. You can also find these as inter-tarsal joints as well as between the
vertebral articular surfaces. So, notice the movement that we only have over here is a gliding
movement, and the articulating surfaces, they're flat. This is your hinge joint over here.
Perfect example is the elbow joint or the inter-ferential joint. So, notice what we have here.
This is your cylindrical shape bone up over here, and then you have the straw-shaped
bone down over here. So, this is where you're going to get this bone fitting over here with this
bone. So, here you go. You can see it. The ulna is the example of the troll over here,
and then the humerus bone. It's going to be the example of the cylinder shape structure of the
the second bone. And what this type of motion allows for is reflection and for extension
to take place. So, again, we state that this is uniaxial movement. So, in this illustration here
is an example of a pivot joint. Now, what you're looking at over here is the proximal surface
between the radius and the ulna. Also, you find this at the Atlanta axial joint. So, what you see
over here is in one bone or one side, you have a sleeve that forms, and that could be either
bone and an ligament. In this case, you have a ligament, and then you have the rounded bone
that's fitted within it. And what this will allow for is uniaxial movement of only for rotation
jerk her. Now, this is an example of the chondra joint over here. And what we see over here are
that both articulating bones, they are oval in their surfaces. So, you have in this picture,
this is an example of the metacarpal phalangeal joint or the knuckle joint. And what we see here
is that we end up getting this biaxial movement. So, one movement allows for flexion and extension
to take place, and that's going to be along the medial lateral axis. And along the anterior
posterior axis, we get abduction and adduction taking place in this chondler joint. Now, as I said,
the saddle joint, you have, it resembles the chondler joint. But remember, in the chondler
joint, the shapes were both oval, and that was a key distinguishing characteristic. In the
saddle joint, one area is concave and the other is convex, but it's not oval in its shape. So,
this is, again, this example occurs at the carpal metacarpal joint of the thumbs. And also, the
motions that you get over here, they're biaxial movement. So, again, for anterior posterior axis,
you're going to get adduction and abduction. And then for the medial lateral axis, you're going to get
flexion and extension to take place. Finally, we have the ball and socket joint. Now, this is an
example of your shoulder joint. You can also find this at the hip joint. So, here you have the head
of the humerus over here. And then it's going to be articulating at the glenoid cavity of your
scapula. So, what we have over here is, again, you have a cup shaped socket, and then you have
this spherical head over the ball of the articulating bone. So, the movements that you get over here,
they are, you get a medial lateral axis, you get flexion and an extension
index that takes place along the anterior posterior axis. You'll get adduction and abduction that takes
place. And then along the vertical axis, you end up getting rotation that takes place. So, again,
this type of joint provides the most movement of, out of any other type of synovial joint. And that's
it for the first part for chapter eight. If you have any questions, please feel free to email me
at my Gmail address. You can find that in the comments below. In addition to that, feel free to
leave comments in the section below as well as sending me a message through YouTube. If you like
the videos, please be sure to give it a thumbs up. Also, share with your friends, and please be
sure to subscribe. When you subscribe, when I have new videos that go up, you guys will be the first
ones to get notifications, and you only have to look around for it. Thank you again, and have a
wonderful day, and best of luck on your exams and your course.